oh we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p
here is a vaccine-related voicemail this
is a new conspiracy
that vaccinated people are
shedding vaccine and if you spend time
with a vaccinated person
you might feel sick because they are
vaccinated this is wild
listen to this hi david my name is
ashley um
i'm currently 18 weeks pregnant and uh
congrats
vaccinated with the both doses of my
five survivor vaccine
feeling very happy about that um but
what i actually want to talk about today
is something i've noticed
spreading in uh anti-vaxx groups i am
not an anti-vaxxer but i have seen this
because my
cousin's wife is a hardcore anti-vaxxer
it is this insane notion that
vaccinated individuals they believe are
shedding
their vaccinated immunity i don't know
what they think it is yeah
two unvaccinated people standing nearby
to the point where it is causing
unvaccinated people
uh to have menstrual irregularities
heart problems they're basically blaming
any medical
new thing that happens to them on
vaccinated people
this is exactly what they're doing so
remember at first many of them were
saying
the vaccine causes problems for the
vaccinated person
affects menstrual cycle all this other
stuff
now many of them have moved on to i
don't want to be near a vaccinated
person because
just it's emanating from their body they
never say are you breathing it out is it
coming out of your eyes is it coming out
of your ears is your skin releasing it
uh is it coming out of body odor they
never say but they're claiming
people are shedding vaccine and it's
making people
around them feel sick and i read about
one employer
i forget what this small small business
said if you get vaccinated you will not
be allowed to come to work because
vaccinated people are shedding vaccine
and making others sick
i'm almost positive that that's against
the law to say you will be fired
if you are vaccinated uh but this is
getting really crazy and this is the
latest front in the anti-vax nonsense
it is wild times but glad you were able
to get vaccinated very very good
we have a great bonus show for you today
we'll talk about wisconsin republicans
killing the medicaid expansion
we'll talk about the latest with my
pillow and we will talk about
an interesting hypothesis about what
jeff bezos is up to
with donald trump's apprentice tapes
okay
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show
get that bonus show my friends sign up
at joinpacman.com one of our sponsors is
four sigmatic the company best known for
their delicious
mushroom coffee four sigmatics mushroom
coffee is organic
fair trade single origin arabica coffee
with both lion's mane and chaga
mushrooms chaga mushrooms have actually
been shown to have potential in
supporting the immune system in
peer-reviewed studies
i've been drinking four sigmatic coffee
a lot lately it actually doesn't taste
anything like mushrooms it just tastes
like any
delicious coffee but it's really easy on
my stomach doesn't give me any jittery
feeling or a midday crash
and they have over 20 000 five-star
reviews and best of all if you don't
love it
you'll get 100 percent of your money
back because
they stand behind their product you've
got nothing to lose by giving
it a try four sigmatic is giving my
audience up to 40 percent off
and free shipping when you go to
4sigmatic.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video